(audience applauding)
- Thank you very, very much.
That was my grandson,
Halfdan, (chuckles) and I was
actually 13 years younger than him
when I wanted to be part
of the actors group.
I wanted to be an actress, and I went
to the theater school in Norway,
and I was going to show them
Juliet in Romeo and Juliet.
I was 17 years old,
but I understood
everything about her story,
and she had just heard
that Romeo was dead,
and now she wanted to take her life,
and she had a glass of poison.
And the way I had studied it by myself,
I didn't speak much to other people,
but I did a lot on my own,
even my first theater thing,
and I came in front of the jury
and I showed them what I
knew about someone's death.
It was a glass of poison,
and what I wanted,
it was to drink this glass
and think of Romeo, and then, slowly,
I would fall down and
down and down on the floor
and die.
And then I heard from
the three jury people,
I heard the oldest of them say,
in the middle of me going
down and down and down,
she said, "Thank you, Liv
Ullmann, this is enough."
(audience laughing loudly)
I cried, and I couldn't understand it
because it was the one thing
I knew I could, it was acting.
And I went home to my grandmother in Oslo
and I rang the doorbell, and she opened,
and I said, (tearfully) "I didn't make it,
and this is what I did, down and down,"
and she looked at me and she
said, "Oh, it's wonderful."
She didn't understand a word of it,
and then she took me
into her bed,
and we were to sleep,
and I was crying and she
put the blanket over us,
and there I was lying so close to her,
and I felt so safe, you know.
I felt this,
this breathing and everything in her neck.
She smelled so well,
and I knew that I belonged,
and she was my best friend.
From when I was 11, we went and saw films.
My whole upbringing
was very often from films,
sitting in the quiet
of the theater and watching the Italians,
Miracolo a Milano, "Bicycle Thieves".
American movies,
I cried with Susan Hayward
and so many others.
I watched them
as a child.
And the jury of my theater
school, where I didn't come in,
they would never believe
what happened to me,
because then a lot of
things happened to me.
As a matter of fact, in Norway,
sometimes, it is impossible to
have something happen to you
because everyone must be alike,
and you have to live by a certain rule,
don't brag, don't show
anything and whatever.
That's why I brought 20 people
from Norway here today. (laughs)
(audience laughing and applauding)
So (chuckles) they can tell Norway
it is true, she got an Oscar!
(audience laughing)
They are very important to me for that.
And I continued my career,
I did a lot of stuff in Norway,
but coming out in the big world,
meeting new teachers all the time,
meeting teachers among
actors, among directors,
among so many things, meeting teachers,
teachers
that made me love to be
part of the painters,
the musicians,
the dancers.
Everything that is part of art,
I was one of them.
Even Richard Rodgers,
you won't believe it,
he wrote a musical for me,
and I don't sing and I don't dance.
He gave me seven songs on Broadway.
(audience laughing)
(Liv chuckles)
I was so lucky,
and then I got to do "Anna Christie",
and John, who I love, and I
haven't seen him for years,
and, well.
(John chuckling)
(audience applauding)
(Liv laughs)
And it was incredible, and
I saw me and I thought,
"Oh, they must know and
see this in Norway."
They had a magazine cover saying,
"This is the new Nordic
star, Greta Garbo,"
and I was walking on Fifth Avenue,
and there Greta Garbo came,
and I was so full of myself,
and I wanted to tell her, "I
am doing 'Anna Christie',"
and I went towards her, and she saw me,
and she got really scared
and she started to run.
(audience laughing)
And I had to run after her
because I had to tell who I was
and why I was and all of that,
and she ran faster and looked at me,
and I ran very fast, too.
(audience laughing)
(breathing heavily) And
we came to Central Park,
and she looked terrified at
me and went into Central Park,
and I never saw her again.
(audience laughing)
And I suddenly, I suddenly
believed one thing,
I was a little full of myself, you know?
I was seeing me,
but I wasn't seeing the other person.
I wasn't recognizing the other person.
And then, when I did this
musical with Richard Rodgers,
and I was to give away a lot of money
because all the actors on
Broadway, they collected money,
so we would help people
who were living in ward
and come with truckloads
of medicals and doctors and nurses,
and all the theaters collected this money,
and I was the one to give it to the head
of the International Rescue
Committee, Leo Cherne.
And I made the speech,
and I gave him the money,
and then I asked, because
my mother brought me up
to do that, "Is there
something else I can do,"
and he said, "Well, we are
going with this truckload
of medicines and doctors,
and so do you want to come with us?"
And I said, "Well, how
long will that take,"
and he said, "It's for
the rest of your life,"
and I went, and my life changed,
this about seeing other people,
recognizing other people,
not only seeing yourself
and recognizing yourself
and what life has given you.
And I came to an island I
didn't know very much about,
where there was a lot of
refugees from Vietnam, Macau,
and I came there and I spoke with people.
And then there was a place in Macau,
where it said, "People with leprosy",
and I wasn't going to go in there,
and then there was a priest,
a Catholic priest, following
me, and he looked at me,
and then I went in
because he looked at me.
(audience laughing)
I came on the inside,
and there on the ground
was lying an old woman,
and she was crying like a baby,
and she was so severed
in her face and her arms,
and he looked at me,
and I knew she's crying, I have to go down
and take care of her,
and so I did it.
And the moment I came close to her
and was holding her and
lifting her up a little,
suddenly she stopped crying,
and then came this sound, (mimics sobbing)
like a little baby does
when it stops crying,
and here, in the neck,
it was the same as my grandmother,
and I realized my grandmother is here.
My mother, my sister,
everybody is here as well,
and it was an incredible change
in what I really believed life was.
I know life is about
finding out who you are
and why you are,
and not so long after, I came to India,
and there was sitting
a girl in an orphanage,
and she was beautiful,
with long black hair,
and we were sitting on her bed
and I did this a little on her hair,
and she did this a little on my hair
because it was longer
then and I was young then.
And suddenly, this little girl
takes off a ring
with a red glass stone,
and she gives it to me
and puts it on my finger.
And I told this story to a Quaker
fundraising things, and they
started to make a fundraising
that this little girl had
organized, and of course,
she does know about it,
but hundreds and thousands
of dollars came in from
the Quakers and fundraising
that went everywhere
because this little girl
gave the one wonderful
thing she had to me,
who had everything,
and that's why I am so sure there is no
the other.
Recognizing is not recognizing
yourself only, but you should
recognize yourself only, I thought,
but it's, in reality, to recognize
other people,
and I'm so grateful
for this.
When I got this call
and it was David, I call
him David, you know,
because he's so gentle,
I've said hello to him
many times since I came,
and he explained why I got this,
I'm so grateful, and that John
would come and give it away.
It somehow makes a circle
in my life, and my friends are here.
They can tell the people in Norway
why I got it, and thank you.
(audience applauding)